if you're shopping for a new car then
you already know this prices are at
record levels the average cost of a new
car has now topped 40
000. oh and by the way used cars are up
nearly 30 percent
in the past year the main reason a
shortage of computer chips
carter evans is at a los angeles car
dealership
carter good morning to you cars are
basically rolling computers these days
so i guess i understand why these little
parts are causing such big problems but
walk me through it
yeah and i want to show you what we're
talking about here these are all
microchips this is from an old laptop i
had and all these little squares here
they're microprocessors well
these new cars behind me they have
hundreds of these chips inside they
control
everything from running the engine to
rolling up the windows but now because
of the shortage some car makers are
scaling back on features others are
shutting down production
altogether and that is bad news if
you're buying a car
the cool part is you can actually put
the seats down when nina and ziska went
shopping recently for a new car
there were a few options and no deals
how much more did you spend than you
wanted to
i probably am spending probably closer
to a hundred dollars more a month than i
wanted to she was hoping to lease the
same model volkswagen jetta that her
brother got
nine months ago for 250 a month she was
quoted 3
15 26 percent higher for the same car
for the same exact car
it's absolutely nuts right now if you
want to buy a new car auto industry
analyst ed kim
says the computer chip shortage is to
blame
so you're not getting any big discounts
on cars oh god no i would say you're
pretty lucky if you're just paying msrp
and there are a good chunk of people who
are paying well over sticker
during the pandemic u.s automakers
temporarily closed factories and
canceled orders for computer chips amid
plunging
sales so chip makers focused instead on
making
smaller chips for electronics like
refrigerators
tvs phones and laptops which are all in
high demand now
once you adapt your supply chain to to
something else
it takes a while to go back i struggled
to see things going back to what they
were you know for another i would say
six to nine months
in the meantime some automakers are
storing unfinished vehicles
ford says it's putting the brakes on
production at some factories this summer
the company anticipates producing more
than a million fewer vehicles this year
costing ford two and a half billion but
at the same time
over the last couple of months we've got
stimulus money rolling in
we've got tax returns coming in so
people are ready to buy a car
and many are now turning to used
vehicles driving prices up
30 percent in may with some models
reselling for more than they did when
they were new
making matters worse rental companies
are scrambling to buy
fleets of cars after selling off nearly
800
000 of them during the pandemic as a
result daily rental car rates more than
doubled many of the rental car companies
have actually been looking to used car
auctions
which is something that just normally
does not happen so what advice would you
give to someone who needs to buy a car
in the next six months
well if at all possible wait because the
supply's so low uh
you know people are having a very hard
time finding the exact configurations
they want
you may need to be you know a little bit
more flexible on those things
well one way to delay a new car purchase
if you're leasing a car
is to try and extend that lease and
experts say if you want to try and get
some sort of a deal then you should
probably consider a sedan
because they're a lot less popular right
now finally
if you have a used car to sell now is an
excellent time to do it
as long as you don't have to buy one to
replace it all right carter evans for us
thank you i think the important part is
point a
to point b you said you were able to
sell your car i was i i got six thousand
dollars over the blue book value but
again then i had to buy
a car so you you end up the exchange is
a little bit it's a serious situation
even the white house
asking for for help and the senate
passing bipartisan legislation to try
and
make sure that there's money going
toward this problem it makes me
nostalgic and i bet a lot of people at
home feel this too for the day when a
computer was a computer and a car was a
car
and they were not the same thing you
know that deal connected now it's the
same thing the dealership
carter's ad is actually where i bought
my car they had 6 000 parts normally
in inventory they told me when i bought
my car about eight weeks ago they were
down to 500 parts
that's where wow shortage is happening
so even if you have to fix your car
you're gonna
have problems carter says come on down
i have another picture there right